[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming out of
here lord added we're coming at you with
another attic show
actually uh hustle we got we got double
the crew today we don't normally have
this many people i can't even i don't
even tell you the last time i have four
people on the attic show like usually uh
we try to keep it a little bit low but
you know it's a crazy stuff man it's
been a slow news week so i had to get
people upon here man uh so first off
let's go over i guess we got lord king
david
and your messy self on twitter how you
been
i've i i heard people was yelling for my
knees dude don't call for me unless i
sent for you my guy on god never man
y'all don't want none of this smoke i
haven't been airing dudes out since i
got on twitter shout out to cognito for
forcing me to get on twitter and i've
been airing you boys out forever and it
ain't gonna stop y'all just backed away
from me so one dude want to put at me
this week like oh look what happened you
calls this upon yourself for what i'm
about to do to you
and i want you to go make a spaces about
this
oh no
oh you you really on the stations thing
aren't you
run tell that
you snitches
so so we we also got uh the one and only
big cloud gaming how how you been my how
you been sir
uh busy guy see that busy guy
busy guy yeah sure
and then we got you know my my co-host
uh we we got hustle motivated so you
know we're not gonna really get we're
not gonna we're gonna dive straight into
it because there's a lot to talk about
here and i have a feeling
king
for sure is is going to speak some
serious bars so let's go ahead and just
go ahead and get straight into it so
first thing i do want to talk about is
we're going to leave the playstation
thing a little bit later for the show
because i know a lot of you because i
know king and his heart loves this one
so apparently i'm going to set this up
for you kim let you go first
but apparently mlb the show
2020
is coming the game past day one and the
moment king found out about this he went
straight to the iop chat and took and
put the tweet in the chat
key how you feel about this
and oh he's oh my god oh god
swing
[Laughter]
are you ready
[Laughter]
oh my god shout out to my favorite
developer in game pass game pass you
know the home
shout out to my favorite
third party developer
shoot without producing you might become
the first party developer get up under
that wing baby give me
y'all looking sweet up in game past day
one how you playstation dudes feeling
right now you gotta pay for it oh that's
a one-off ain't gonna get it next year
we caught it you know that's not you
know that's not the narrative we pay for
our game seven listens
we pay five go pay for this that's what
they do we play our games
you you pay we play
[Laughter]
yo i can't that's the best place to play
i pay yo listen i can't front right now
jim ryan has got to be the greatest
instep ceo
that i've ever seen over
at
sony
he's lockstep
he is not playing he's not missing any
moves he don't watch james brown
he don't watch jim c hammer
he he don't watch the great michael
jackson he even threw in a couple of
moves from prince
and i ain't gonna front man those knees
be we poverty at the bojangles doing it
he was laughing i was like oh boy out
here with the electric boogie
t-shirts so good
you dudes y'all just don't y'all just
didn't even see it coming the way y'all
been bamboozled hood winked and let it
straight no king now king that's why i
have to ask you how long have i been
warning you
i don't know how long have i been saying
like just warning people on youtube
his knife is good though i'm just saying
though i know i think he's in that what
was that game that y'all y'all love so
much gochushima
can we
can we take a second to tell big cloud
stop acting like you're the only person
up here to
saying the the the gossip man we we've
all been saying the same stuff and big
cloud will come in and be like i'm the
one that first
i've been telling people for years i'm
talking about
he's been the loudest dude on their side
and and not yelling for oh he needs to
be uh taking out his head
i hear a lot of those dudes
screaming uh oh jim ryan needs to go
let me tell you something
before jim ryan you weren't profitable
you had a bunch of failed products that
was uh that was inside uh development
and he went in and he cleaned stuff up
you had a a homeboys only club that was
over there you know just because you was
godfather and
you didn't think you can get canned oh
no you got reallocated into making demos
for the new playstation
we got to see how this controller work
all right so go make a game about that
you're going to be productive in jim's
world in gym space you're going to make
sense
if it don't make dollars it don't make
sense and jim is about that game past
life this is about mlb to show day one
just to clarify king because you know
people are going to go in that chat and
say this that this is a jim ryan move
this is an mlb
uh making a sign with uh xbox this is
jim ryan's the one that had the last
call here correct
let me say something
i don't care who the hell pull the
trigger
your head is on the on on the front of
the company your face is on front of the
company if america goes right now and
does something crazy biden gonna have to
pay for that right so at the end of the
day you are the head of the company i
don't care what it smell like i don't
care what it looked like you could have
said okay you know what mob we're not
going to be associated with that go do
your thing
i'm not going to take my brand this way
but you know what they saw they saw them
sweet figures
they said yo they really do play games
over here
yo look at look at like this they saw a
nintendo they saw the nintendo like
number that's one of those
and let me tell you something
that's a worse blow for you dudes yeah
yeah mlb the show is on the go
no this
is wild because i remember i got
crucified i don't know if i was on yah
show when i brought that up when i said
dudes do more talking about playstation
games yeah and actually buying a sport
or was boom [ __ ] it was one to two i got
crucified he was like no there's no way
no just like there's no way to do that
we buy the games i buy them day one or
i'll get them on sale that's my goddamn
point you get them on sale you don't get
them where it matters you don't buy why
do you think the day is gone developers
going through so many damn hurdles and
he's in these interviews he's talking
about the game
to be honest with you like that whole
mindset from that whole side of not
trying to save money like blows them all
my mind they're like oh
the opportunity to you're going to act
like you don't want it all right so
there you go yeah that's that's the only
thing but my thing is when you buy it on
sale
you're hurting sony's bottom line
exactly they're taking a loss to give it
to you exactly so obviously
you are the problem
right so
when it when it comes to game pass they
got their bag up front
yeah now all that engagement that's up
inside there now see see it's
it's like when you go into an
all-inclusive vacation
you paid everything up front now
everything is afforded to you some of
you dudes have never been to
all-inclusive let me explain how it goes
you put up the big bread first so that
means your flight
your room your board
the bar the food
that stuff is good then they tell you
little extras
you have to pay for a little extra so
that mini bar in your room be careful
that's going to hit your wallet that's
micro transactions in the baseball right
so sometimes you can't help it sometimes
you don't want to go outside you're
going to hit that mini fridge
and they restock the mini fridge every
day and they will always have something
that appeals to your appetite right so
then you might order something off the
menu later on late night at night
so
this is the micro transactions this is
where microsoft makes their money this
is what mob the show really starts to
shine because they got their upfront
money there's no sales here this is no
bargain basement stuff you know what's
going to can they make money you know
what's going to kill me on twitter when
i see the flip-flop from
remember
before the narrative the narrative still
is game passes the enemy game passes
ruling in the industry vice versa these
developers not getting paid all this
stuff yet here we are and let's keep it
a buck y'all seen the the leaks right
all the leaks majority of the leaks in
terms of sony's direction
and like certain features whatnot right
they've been on the money
this playstation infinite i don't know
they're gonna call it that but whatever
the hell this subscription service
they're working on this game pass-like
competitor it might come this year it
might not come this year
but whatever the name of this this uh
service is when this drops y'all already
know one big thing is going to change
the narrative the goal post it happens
every single time we start from here
when sony does it oh it's good let's
move it back
let's make amends for it you know i mean
so when he puts again sony puts the game
on pc
oh it's fine uh well the the sequel they
on pc but yet
here we are
the mindset before him was oh i'm done
with playstation if that game goes to
set pc and yet where they acting they
still want the console and that's why i
say it before it's like
people with the mindsets kill me because
it's like you're not going anywhere
hustle addict they'll tell you a lot of
you dudes won't last you want to tell
you what because there's more hassles
for sure a lot of hassles and you're not
going to go through it you're not going
to be what you're comfortable for for
something that you're unfamiliar with
you know what they're going to do
what they're going to do what's up
they're gonna go buy a little man
and get in pocket like jim
let's be real king
that's not all they're gonna do they're
gonna buy a little man
and not tell anybody they play at xbox i
i'm listening i'm pretty sure that i'm
playing with a lot of those things right
now under presudio names that's my
friends that play with me every day and
it could be somebody else that's a
well-known cat well remember you're back
in the day
they kill me they're afraid to tell you
that they buy or they play on xbox and i
was like dog who cares remember
remember back in the day when
people
that were playing destiny was like
they'd appeared offline to not show
people they playing destiny yeah that's
what's going to happen on on
the playstation show with this xbox like
look i'm going to get these super chats
here in a second but it's like
mlb the show is a big platform and i
will say that microsoft has done a
fantastic job
with
making up to the fact that their viewers
their consumers haven't had that game
ever it is like look like we get it it
took us a while we got in here it's like
and not only did we get that in the room
we're going to let you in the vip club
so
it's like
it's nice and what's funny is
is it was bad last year and then
the fact that they announced the so the
uh not the the the bungie thing the same
day
what what was crazy well let me get
these uh these super chats real quick so
we got a five dollar superstar from here
avo ps fans waiting for master chief
collection
like lord uh king why is they uh binding
what is they binding i don't know what
you mean by that what
what did he say jps fans waiting for
hello master chief collection like and
it's a dead it's a skull emoji so they
did
um
lord king what is thy bidding oh okay
he's asking for like what is my video
okay listen
we're gonna we're gonna address that
topic in a second and i think you're
gonna have you're gonna take away so
much fun bars that you can clip and you
can post and you can tease your friends
with because i got some stuff for you
and this and on this show that is really
going to take twitter
and do a blowtorch to it
this could get real
good we got it youtube chat from pixel
uh bit g
jim did say they were not uh they were
not enough so this is true
he said y'all wasn't good enough he said
that's he said that's cool but that's
that's not we need that pc crowd to get
those sales too no i'm gonna tell you
right now
once he got that money
from that game pass
and once they realized that
dude these dudes don't stop
buying stuff like dude another check
came in this month
what
microsoft check
caulfield i didn't want to um i didn't
want to speak on that so the month that
um the game came out around july of you
know it came out in april but around
july of that year i'm looking at the
numbers now it sold two million across
all platforms and then they reached for
and they reached four million players so
yeah and not to mention
what's up that
that fat check they got king from
microsoft for putting it on game pass
yeah microsoft paid them whatever they
paid them and um yeah the mlb you know
mlb was like hey you know
mld was always um
what was the word for the streets
a lot of people didn't really battle
eyelash at mlp that's the thing too on
the planet they took it for granted they
that's that's what you take first
and i've been trying to tell you
playstation dude for a minute we got god
of war it ain't going on pc wake up
little suzy wake up
um
we got we got we got
that's never going to pc
we got naughty dog and
wake up
yeah
dudes
those days is over right now they told
you you ain't enough all right y'all
capping that's 125 first of all you
brought one
right and and maybe if you like me maybe
you got two and three inside your house
because you don't feel like carrying
your
your console up to the next room you
know when you get kicked out of one room
you just go load up in the next room
so if you purchase one talk about that
one you purchase that one game stop
talking about these millions but
financially in this day and age it's not
feasible
to game in the capacity that you want to
game that old style at old thought i'mma
get this game and i'm going to platinum
this game and i'm going to squeeze every
ounce of juice out of this game that i
can possibly squeeze out when game pass
drops i'm like on the 20th
15 games
so you think that little 70 purchase
means anything to the 500 deal that i
just got that just dropped into my lap i
do i never want to be you
like i never want to be you i want to be
the 500 you're hurting the industry but
but you're hurting the industry support
the developers 70 dollars every game who
cares about your deal
[Laughter]
i don't care like i really i'm a gamer
so i want to get as much gains for the
least amount of money that i can spend
especially at times like this bro
you know what's correct
what did i say addict what did i say i
said when when when you increase the
price with the price of anything that
magnifying glass gets bigger
and people look at what you're getting
for that price point
this is why a lot more people have been
very picky i ain't got a job but you've
been very picky with playstation games
it's just that simple the games that are
established they're going to be fine
sure they'll do they'll be fine horizons
already a maid game it's going to do
good before we're part two let's keep it
a buck games like destruction all-stars
never had an opportunity they were never
going to take off yeah that game was
never going to take off for 70 bucks but
people were lobbying you murdered also
they were alive and you paid seven
dollars for that until it went to
playstation plus they saw all trash
they're like oh you know what i'm glad i
didn't get 70 dollars listen this is
what i'm talking about dudes need to
understand and pay attention what you're
getting i love that like it's
the crazy part that blows my mind
is just how
how dismissive people are when you talk
about oh yeah i got game passes oh i i
paid full price for my stuff i never do
anything in there and i'm just like so
you pay like they like okay so when you
go into into the dealership you just pay
it all in cash you yeah nothing else
like everything you can no i i'm talking
but these people on twitter
they don't even have a car at all that's
what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying it's it's like
it's like dude like you do this in other
aspects of your life but for some reason
these are the same people that will
will subscribe to netflix all year long
uh
because listen you know what the fear is
at it and i told dudes from the
beginning
that you can't pay that money
when you can't pay that month
the lock is on the door
like so it's it's it's a fair
it's it's an absolute fare that you
don't have at 15 that month and you are
locked out from the fun
so okay so let's get to this part right
any time i do purchase a game or for
game pass i get 10 percent discount
let's say the game is about to leave
game pass let's say the game was inside
game pass for at least a year some
change the price on that game then
dropped down and i still get the 10
off
on my deal
so let's say it's no longer 50 60 bucks
and they had a sale on this game and
this game now is like 35 i still get
that ten percent off
but before it leaves guess who owns that
digital piece that little copy that
little token
a lot of you dudes is out here capping
for nfts and bitcoins and all this other
stuff where is it at in your hand
oh you're saying no i ain't gonna do
none of that nft and none of that
bitcoin stuff i'm worried about this
cold hard cash
the diamonds and the gold i need to have
that in my hand no
so if you if if you're using that same
brain let's let's use the brain that you
got
you're going to love this so i'm looking
at the chat uh what they say
the mark is the dog
let me let me eat this okay so you said
that place he put it in colors
you put it in gold no no no i got it
addressing it no that guy said it's good
he came at me earlier no but don't
listen to him
listen if you really want his voice
heard he will put some money behind he
you want to learn
even putting money behind your words
because you're not strong behind your
convictions so the moment you decide to
say that your convictions and your words
mean something you hit that money you
see that button right there with put a
dollar behind your words put some weight
behind you
at least two dollars before you could
say anything well let somebody have to
say your words let some let's when you
go to the courtroom you pay your lawyer
to talk for you right well you better
pay that lawyer to talk to you because i
can't see you anyway back to our
conversations like what we were talking
about
real quick i had to
put the color on for the attic show so
king can see me
oh no
these dudes out here jabba talking all
you can do it all you want down there
when you want me to see what you're
talking about put some bars behind your
words i'm not looking at that and you
know what i'm talking about there we go
uh here ivo this acquisition was like
buying a 28 uber and someone else got
the right
yo
well uh king i think you said it earlier
um in the conversation
if i'm sony san diego i would have let
that i would have let it go i would let
mlb go
i'm gonna let it go cause obviously at
that point you make something else i
gotta read this one i gotta read this
song king it's tough to super chat when
you drop in 77 a
game we got a two dollar super trap from
flame dab king be going for the throat
get him yeah it it is what it is you
don't understand like these dudes want
to be here this is this is not a a blog
post that we're gonna sit there and read
your joint because i'm not i got on
shades bro
unless i see color pop up me if i can't
see you
they say see you know when you really
get king when you take the shades off to
read like that's right
we gotta we we got a super chat from i'm
definitely gonna butcher this
oh my god i got something right
oh so someone clip that king said you
gotta pay to play
this is a fact this is what they like to
do right that's it
look i don't know i never thought we'd
be like that though where damage control
was seventy dollars seventy dollars yeah
that's why i understand i never thought
we'd be there i understand the mindset
where
i want to own the product which is the
majority a lot of these games are online
only like so you don't really own it
but
when you go on someone's timeline and
start attacking people
because they're subscribed to a
subscription service
it is crazy and a lot of these people
are low-key behind closed doors getting
ubisoft played to play one of the
assassins creeds for a couple days and
not telling anyone
so it's like it is it's only okay when
it's actually
relevant to their conversation that's
why they won't tell people that's why i
said back in the day people would be
clowning us on playing destiny but what
they doing behind closed doors king they
go they appearing offline because they
they don't want to give us the narrative
of roasting them the next time they come
but then they hit me in the dm could you
get me through this raid king oh man
he said can you get me through this
right
there is not anybody yo they they
capping seventy dollars you know for a
sports game
yeah i want you i want you to take that
in for a second it's a sports game that
cost seventy dollars which you probably
would have traded back in after eight
months of having it anyway not a new
sports game
not to mention
though for a sports game but what are we
doing
and uh at the madden i mean a lot of
these sports games you're looking at
them spooky and not to mention
especially
gamers about the trap too what about
that stuff spooky
the crazy part is people didn't really
say anything
when sony's charging ten dollars to
upgrade a previous shin games like it
wasn't like there were certain people
that was saying something but for the
most part it was crickets and it's like
my sony's like okay we you know we gonna
get the seventy dollars for the brand
new reason why
yeah i had this conversation with you
before but the reason why i do is really
think that this
this little controller here uh with the
haptics automatically justifies you you
paying an additional fee to access this
mind you the competition offers all that
stuff
at no additional cost and you know mind
you the competition is giving you free
upgrades
with no additional costs
what color what color is that analog
what are we paying
you subconsciously want to be part of
the green machine so you might as well
just do it yo bit let me tell you
something you know
when when when they when they say stuff
like that they're gonna tell you that
microsoft has to do that because they're
losing
right
yeah
you don't work for sony
you don't get a check from sony
you don't get an endorsement you don't
even get a heads up from sony
yo we're dropping playstations so you
can actually get one that you've been
capping from for since last year
um
so
you're a gamer right
worry about that part
yeah
worry about
okay
70 looks like it's a bit out of whack
when everybody else is at 60 and
everybody else is giving you free
upgrades to usher you into the next
generation where one is taking a hard
stance
excuse me and then reverse that same
stance
right back in front of you because they
said that you weren't enough
and they need the money from the
previous generation
to get into the black because they're in
the red
to make these deals and then they told
you
uh you know pc wasn't in our plans then
they go out and get nexus which is my
heart that's my heart
and then these game starts coming over
and being ported over to the pc because
the pc
introduces a revenue stream and then
they tell you that games will be pointed
over to rival consoles
yeah you know
and doing this hold on in doing this
y'all you dudes been saying for a long
time it's been deteriorating the brand
you don't represent the brand
right like you you're not a ceo for the
company mm-hmm you you won't get fired
if you go and jaywalk and get arrested
from sony they don't care about you
so stop talking like you represent the
brand you represent games go game and
get the best deals for your dollar when
you start valuing yourself you can stop
looking for value in others exactly they
put themselves they project themselves
in the box and that's what they should
do and that's that's true and that's not
it that's not it that's why obviously
that's what i've always been just go
where the games are you know when when
the bungie thing was announced the first
thing i tweeted is look it depends on
how this deal goes which you know we're
about to talk about here in a couple
minutes but
i might be playing destiny on
playstation you didn't see me tweeting
the president to ask them to stop it
like that ain't gonna happen yeah i
don't know where are they getting it
dude's like hey oh sony you need to buy
these guys my brother they're not
listening to your silly tweet what are
you doing
like stop it's not it's not like that
we'll get to it in a minute but um yo
let's let's keep it real yo it's a
sports game it should have been it
should have been on all platforms in the
first place exactly
i never like i've never heard in the
like the history of gaming like a first
party sports game and then
on top of that
at that period of time
everybody was making sports games you
know like a baseball game you had uh
nintendo making their own baseball game
you have um microsoft
rbi baseball you know baseball games was
prevalent all over the place until uh
sony locked down a licensee and you got
to blame
for that
ea is the culprit when it comes to doing
stuff like that and then you got to look
at take two when they made sure that uh
2k was the prevalent basketball game
where uh live couldn't breathe
so
with stuff like that yeah when we have
verbations in the market of that type of
magnitude that forces people to lock
down whole licenses and put it behind a
wall garden
yeah it's advantageous at that period of
time when those metrics dictate that
type of thought
everything has changed now mlb the show
said you're not enough so
what jim said was it was a point in time
in his head
the market was good here
yeah mlb the show said listen
puerto plata
all right this this
all right either you're gonna take the
the gold or the lead
one or the other papa because let me
tell you something we're gonna make this
move
so what he did he got down jim's not
crazy then when he got the bag he sees
the situation
he will you won't ever hear sony talk
bad about that situation
in their brains
they're trying to calculate how they can
get more of their product
into that ecosystem
to get the reoccurring dollar
no
next to nothing the return on their
investment as well is awesome yes
speaking of volumes to this dude didn't
they get like a 90 percent return
and you know
you know what's crazy about
the mlb the show thing
instead of being realistic about the
matter and saying look it will be the
show and sony feel like they can
capitalize on this because it's a sports
game it should probably be where
everywhere anyway instead of being
realistic like that you had people
that's like sony you should have just
refused to make the game and let it go
what
about that by the way yeah you know what
i'm gonna have a good experience because
you want to be petty oh and you said
this or no other age is dumb to me
just just to clarify you said that you
stand by them abandoning the movie the
show i'd love it alone i'd have had a
sony um san diego studios i had them
working on something else it was you
know i just had them working on
something else though
so so hold on let's break this down a
little bit let's break this down what is
the mindset behind no no no there's no
wrong answers here uh what is the
mindset behind that opinion though like
why do you feel that way
i feel like in order for me to
because you either gotta get down to lay
down because the mlb wasn't playing
either
in order for me to do that like that
joint would have had like because i
don't know what the final cells are like
that joint would have to move instead of
like the one million that it moves
annually that joint would have to do 10
times that in order for me to like stick
around because i feel like it's not
worth it at that point and
like pharrell
something like if i'm not even like a
playstation fanboy but something like
just wouldn't have sat right like you
got to make this you got to make this
for everybody after being exclusive all
that time and mlb we stepped in we all
know that but
just
just like i got pride though like yo
like nobody was copping that baseball
like that anyway no it wasn't no yeah i
know that is true that is true i know i
don't want to i don't i don't i don't
believe
that
and and the reason why i don't believe
it is
i have friends
that wait every year for mob to show
the same way i got friends that way
every year for 2k and every year for
madden i think he's trying to solve it
listen if madden 2k was locked down to a
specific console
they will be locked down to that
specific concept yeah yeah king king
hold on i don't want the only one going
to a back and forth you know there's a
difference between the mlb
no no no no no no
let me tell you something yes
predominantly
my family is made up of dominicans and
puerto ricans okay so you talk football
to them they talking about soccer soccer
right all right so and then you talk
about the west indian side of me i i
can't even talk madden to nobody you
understand because they bringing up fifa
so it's fight for me definitely
you definitely can't talk bad to me
because i'll be like what are you
talking about you understand so
i'm coming from a different a culture
set right my culture said it's different
so when when when you say mlb this show
is now
available in game my my cousin said
mlb the show
is on xbox
game pass
that's why i did that video
and it was so funny because i did it
because that's the same voice that he
used in my head when he was screaming my
ears oh
he said i don't have to play my
playstation no more bro
this is it this is it we gonna play i
don't want to hear no excuses no more
we're going to play some baseball
i want to mention one last thing i do
want to mention one last thing before so
i can wrap up all right it's a nintendo
switch and it's cross-play all over yes
yeah that's that's wow
did you see that that thing that bg
shared it looked like it was like one of
those oh
it's a nintendo switch gameplay leaks
i saw that yeah
you're going to see this game be exactly
what it's supposed to be if it's the
pinnacle of the sport yeah it's supposed
to be visible
like the sport
not locked down
when ea did that
they changed how sport games were looked
at across
all genres yeah so
the ea is the bad culprit here sony just
follows suit to survive and it's so and
this is a this is a underlining tone
with sony and we're going to get into
their level of survival and what sony
does to survive at all costs all the
time and you will notice that they
aren't exactly the homegrown
beautiful uh doe-eyed baby blue-eyed
dude you think they are
let's get these super chats we'll move
on to the to to the the bungee talk man
so we gotta find all the super chat from
gaming forte
i wish someone would
come after me for not buying games i
bought games for years and i bet i have
more digital game purchases than most of
you haters yeah i think that last time i
checked out like 711 or something like
that ridiculous
yeah and then we got
i finally picture from andrew courtney
subscription services are all a value
proposition they
they aren't for everyone but those uh
but for those who want it game pass is a
fantastic value
nothing but facts then we got five
dollars supers from john wolff
great show
hey ps console warriors don't forget
that
ps uh acquired bungie because of
microsoft in the words of king who did
that for you
yeah that's funny we got uh we got a 10
superstar from drunty uh drawn tj
hi lords do you think microsoft and
sonia are working together behind the
scenes buying companies to preserve the
gaming industry and keep it from apple
intension that's that's a very
interesting thing
yeah i i don't think that's it i think
that they're
microsoft i we're about to get to the
bungee thing here in a second so you
know we'll get more into you know
exactly the company
going in two different directions with
two different goals
yep you pretty much got that company for
sure is the one one wants one massive
service the other one is doing this
thing yeah you got a company like
microsoft that wants to really be the
first big person in the subscription
hall so they're buying all these
platforms to make sure they have content
for the subscription service and then
you got sony panicking and buying
whatever they can scrap up oh man that
was a five month out deal i don't
believe it was a panic
no no
it wasn't a panic to the activision
thing we'll go let's go and get it
so bungie was bought
by sony and okay so first off i want to
say is when it comes to this particular
thing this one did hit a little close to
me a little close a little bit you know
because there for a second i was
thinking
damn
i was like i might have to play
everything on playstation when it comes
to destiny but the good thing
is
is this thing right here
and i dropped my controller but that's
fine oh this thing right here is a
thousand times better than that than
that uh dual shock force so i could
probably i could rock with this
i could definitely rock with this i came
to y'all senses i see okay
[Laughter]
playstation
bought bungie it was a big thing and i i
will say this this is huge news you know
regardless how people feel about destiny
and regardless how you know kids move
made like a 12 9 12 minute video saying
bungie's not worth 3.6 billion
the thing is is sure maybe the company
itself wasn't worth that but you don't
buy a company for what they're worth
like you literally go to anyone that's
doing well and offer them what they're
worth they're gonna laugh you out of the
office you have to put that cherry on
top like do you like do you activision
was not worth
the money it was worth but they had put
that cherry on top to get that deal out
you got to purchase the debt
yeah yeah
these dudes don't understand what goes
behind deals
all right so let's let's break this down
first off insomnia that's not the only
one what i want to ask that clean thing
first thing i want to ask is we're going
to start with hustle is hustle do you
think
and now just keep in mind let's just
answer this question because there's a
lot we have to go over with bungie and
uh activision do you think that this is
a reactionary buy from
microsoft buying studios the way they
are
yes
it is not the most recent one obviously
because this deal and i'm kind of glad
we waited till some news came out
this took over around five months so
this is definitely a reactionary thing
because
as we all know playstation don't really
have any multiplayer games
they don't
really have any multiplayer games
outside of like call of duty let's see
what the last of us was over there i
think resistance was over there once
upon a time
they show calm they would come
yo socon was on playstation 2. like just
look at how far back big cloud went yeah
like so they they definitely needed
multiple i have a theory about them and
but i'll with the adventure point now
okay yeah i know i mean i want to make
sure you excite i kind of want to take
this one nice and slow this is like the
surgical summer from pusha t man because
hey look i'm gonna be real with you yeah
playstation bought bungee but it seemed
like bunkie came out the victims of this
deal and i guess we'll get into that a
little bit more like
the structure of that deal to me i don't
think i've ever seen anything like that
because i know bungie was independent
but we'll get right back to it so let me
ask you a question first addict okay
yeah it's reactionary but it's not
reactionary to the most recent deal it's
reactionary to the previous deals that
was going on narrative yeah so so king
do you think that this is a reaction
okay let's
i'm gonna broaden it a little bit more
do you think if microsoft wouldn't up
here dropping money like it's hot like
they know tomorrow and buying all these
studios buying bethesda buying all the
shoes they bought 2018. do you think
this bungee thing happens
yes
you do
yeah well this this is five months uh in
the past let's let's let's let's look at
the history of how loose bungie is uh-oh
all right so bungie is the and listen uh
okay
for all you new millennials or whatever
with your classifications
i identify as him and he
okay
so all of my stuff will be geared in
that manner so before you get your
panties into punch
him and he
okay
now
bungie
loves the court and phase
bunji is the type of girl that
she she loves the dating she loves the
flowers she loves the honeymoon she
loves the ring she loves to get down on
the knee she loves talking to her
friends here proposed it's a beautiful
thing
so when microsoft came through the first
time and she got married the first time
oh my god he did it i can't believe it
oh my god this is amazing they had three
beautiful children together
then she became a housewife
and she said um
i don't want to do this no more
there's no more romance in this
you're not you're not giving me the
flowers and microsoft like what are you
talking about i got your rule for you
you're fed the lights what else you want
me to do i'm doing every what are you
talking about this is not working out
the kids stay with me you can get the
hell on go home oh no
so halos has stayed here
she hit the bricks
next dude saw activision hey mom you
looking sweet
um she like oh tell her friends yo he
talking to me he ruined me giving me the
rings and the things and i i got this
you know i'm thinking about a new name
for my kid it'd be destiny
oh that's uh that's what's up
let's do this
so they get married
they had two kids together
and then he tries to domesticate her
by telling her when he wants her to to
to to get the food out the refrigerator
and getting all this stuff oh hell no
hell no activision
i had this in my last relationship
i went out and this time i'm taking it
this analogy is crazy
listen she takes the kids this time
she gone
so she got she got her name she she
pulled the tina turner i want my last
name
she took that oh my god
so right now she was rolling stone
rolling
so
she come back to microsoft
she oh you got this game pass thing
remember we could get back to how we
used to do it oh my god
so she was talking to michael so for a
minute we all thought they was really
booed up because we see them at games
together and they doing all this type of
stuff together we think they they're
about to get shaq back up microsoft
can't get any sense and say hell no ma
you crazy you for the streets
oh my god so hear the dude at the end of
the ball
see her sipping her little cognac in the
corner
with her cougar eyes
and she looking over
and my man jim slider and say hey mom
somebody somebody somebody clipped us
please this is getting clipped i said
what's up
say um
you down hank yeah but listen listen
before we take this any place further
i want an open relationship if this is
going to be anything
i want to be able to be anywhere i want
to be at any time i want to be there
if you ain't doing right by me i want to
be able to walk out the doors
and in his desperation
he looked over and said you know what
i don't got no multi-plats and i don't
got no first person shooters that matter
and you are you you are the queen of
making these first-person shooters go
bang
and you definitely got that multiplied
joint you got any other stuff you're
working on yeah i got this stuff over
here
i want a big wedding i want a bigger
wedding than i ever had
and i want you to announce it to all
your friends cause you gonna tell all
your friends you're with me
i got you boo
and the tweet go out
sonia quiet bungie
for the low low price of 3.6
and she get she booed up again until the
moment sony says something slick out his
mouth
and she not feeling that domestication
again she back outside on the streets
but she got exactly what she want at all
times this is the only company that i've
ever seen
finesse dudes at and and we're just
sitting there like how do they keep from
getting finessed by the
marcus
said no you got a good point there
shout out to bungie for literally going
up to it it's literally they're like yo
we could we could we could talk man but
you know we we could be that friends
with benefits but you you're gonna you
you're gonna make me you're gonna you're
gonna sign a prenup because if this
isn't it i'm leaving and you ain't doing
nothing about it and they didn't do that
to one company they did that to 2.
no this last this last contract
is the worst
because she said
i don't care
if you like to have everything to
yourself i'm for the streets
so and you're gonna put that in your
press conference you're gonna put that
in your little your little tweet your
little package that you're gonna put out
rival consoles
it's nintendo getting destiny too
[Laughter]
this is amazing hey hey i do want to say
man like yo
bungie they pampered super strong
because i do want to go back a little
bit they got so much they they got a lot
of leverage
yeah well you know they make their own
leverage yeah they're saying
yeah what's up what do i was gonna say
before they made halo first of all that
game was supposed to go to apple when it
was supposed to be a third-person game
or a real-time strategy game what
happened apple phone
financed that in the beginning
microsoft came and took them out of the
fire they said hey you say we need you
all right quick and that's how microsoft
actually ended up with halo it was like
yeah look we'll sign y'all but we need
we we need master chief and then they
got it ever since yo ever since then
like i swear like whoever's that bungie
took that personal thought
they they dip from um
they're from microsoft right they're
different xbox they dip from activision
the second thing is start to go wrong
they're out and like i'm 3.6 billion
like first of all 3.6 billion just to
have it a multiplayer everywhere they're
all working on another project but we
don't know you know what the confines of
it are yeah yeah exclusive thing but i'm
gonna be honest with you the way the way
bungie carrying it right now though
you know the funny thing about it
kind of how i kind of read it at first
until you like really look into like the
the extra of it you know like how
they're going to go remaining themselves
that's fine no no like how i read it at
first i thought it was going to be
similar to like it because it sounded
similar at first so you read into it uh
similar to the bethesda acquisition or
call of duty one like because they go
hey we were made you know these games
are continuing to go just right third
until you actually read it and they flat
out tell you like no
sony supports our vision of
multi-platform and what i heard
multi-platform now it's funny again
me i'm i'm very fair i'm very fair i'll
sit back i'll hear it i'll hear it you
know take i'll doubt give you mine i'll
say how it is for a while now i've been
hearing uh a lot of playstation dudes in
particular call microsoft a third party
yeah literally
i've been hearing that a lot
i'm like
see i just gave you all the setup yeah
i'm gonna give you the finish and i'm
looking at this i'm gonna go okay so
microsoft is a third party they're not
making clinical games they're just gonna
be a publisher they're gonna drop
everything on playstation even though we
already know we already got a lot of uh
big parts or should i see information
for a lot of these games especially for
bethesda
and when we look at the situation with
uh
activision
what do we know so far by activision
sony's going to get
three cod games that's it
we haven't heard nothing more about four
we haven't heard four or five we know
three and minus those three games were
put on a table they're made on the table
but long before this acquisition even
happens type of field
you're getting those
i don't know where they're getting this
mindset for this but now we got sony
over here over here at my agent that's
why i'm a tag in hustle
you brought up no multiplayer games how
many times i said that with you we need
that we need most players this is the
studio to go to
to get certain games coming back
remember how they tweeted out socom
they keep tweeting out resistance i
really think bungie's going to lend her
expertise
in those games with the multiplayer side
of this we'll tell you why because face
it fashion two
factions two is going to be good right
we know we play fashion it's gonna be
good but let's face it fashions two is
not a halo it's not like a crazy you
know it's not it's not that type of game
this is a fun game you play it's not
gonna happen like even if they did
something crazy when they try to add
some mog
type of esports element to it right it's
not gonna work with last of us that's
not the game for it you need something
different therefore you got to bring
back you have to go back in the treasure
chest you got to bring back the hitters
and resistance
and socom are the
likely ones that makes sense
insomnia games he's tweeted you know
signed me you know they telling you like
oh we're just showing off our history of
the game
this time yeah you've been showing off
the history of this damn game for damn
near a year and a half what are you what
are you doing clearly there's something
going on with this game there's just let
it out stop the cap
so
we know that's happening but this is the
studio to get that multiplayer going the
single player is fine but the thing
about sony they don't have a game with
the longevity of a multiplayer that
matters hell they have potential of one
the order 1886 could have been potential
with a horde mode type of multiplayer if
we got in a sequel we don't have
and and yeah we won't get it well at
least i don't think we're going to get
it because ready
facebook or apple right yeah um i came
before y'all going before y'all going i
just want to say what a time to be alive
right a couple weeks ago activision
signed with microsoft yeah we have crash
bandicoot and then spyware the dragon
which were the playstation ips that they
invented by the way
i think believe naughty dog invented
those
over there with that team green
and now we got the creator halo over
there with
we're over there with everybody i was
going to say team blue but they're kind
of over there with everybody right now
but we do live in the reality right we
live in a reality where
you know bungie for all intents and
purposes could actually make a halo
killer not like resistance well not like
killzone rather but it couldn't really
make a hand they could make a good thing
they took that with destiny destiny was
number one
these three
and then they have that mmo that's
coming out called uh what's the mmo
called it project matter yeah matter
um because the only thing that matters
right now is their pockets
so hold up real quick i just want to say
one thing right
and a lot of you guys are gonna probably
you know try to come for me
i respect jim ryan in such the way that
yeah yeah i said he was at the bar and
he saw her with cool guys and he said
hell yeah whatever he took
well what jim understands and what jim
knows is
when he purchases them in their entirety
they have a movie division
you can make destiny the movie the tv
show you could you can sell that over to
to netflix for the tv show to go along
with all the other stuff that you got
going over to netflix is a tv show look
at this package here they don't have
first-person party shooters
of note
they made haze it didn't work they made
resistance it didn't work they made
kills on it didn't work so why not go
get the father of the best console
shooter ever made
yeah right i think that's gonna have
lightning in a bottle make something new
you have the dna strands today even
though everybody's at 343 i'm not gonna
say nothing but you're gonna hurt you're
gonna hear it though
you purchased the show but
the soul is over here um
but
at the same time
the biggest deficiency sony addressed
and it was necessary to do so in light
of the onslaught of what microsoft is
doing is they multiplayer deficit and
they did that in one fell swoop with one
slice of the sword
they fix three different categories so
you can't say that this is a weak move
this is a strong move made out of power
but again
when i tell you this is the last
playstation console this is the har
bringer of doom
because they're telling you
in the paperwork
supporting rival consoles as a as an
effective part of their dna going
forward now
if you're looking
is going to have reverberations
throughout the boardroom
and once the boardroom starts to see
certain amounts of money
and once jim continues to produce
in certain amounts of ways
there's no going back
there's no going back from microsoft in
the way that phil has put mike xbox in
microsoft eyes microsoft looks at xbox
as a viable commodity now
right so you're seeing them doing
acquisitions he will go down as the
greatest
ceo in microsoft history
jim is going to do the same thing for
playstation
what direction he takes him in
is solely up to jim
and i don't think
he likes consoles
oh you're bringing out that
real quick before we get into all of
that let me get these super chats i'm
super chats wow boy
okay first off i don't have sovereign
here so
some of you with your names you're gonna
have to
accept the fact i'm about to
mispronounce them no i'm i'm i'm a
reader but it's gonna be mispronounced
so we got a five dollar supernatural
from lucious augustus
butchered that first one i think i got
the second one but we're going to move
past that
mention
jeff grubb mentioned that the move was
finalized recently they've been working
on it for a while but it could have
fallen through if not for abk all right
let's pause on that because i do want to
talk about this real quick so keep this
tweet in mind we got a two dollar
shooter kendrick hardy bungie is the
jennifer lopez of publishers what is
king star
listen let me tell you something i was
going to use that reference before
but it's not appropriate in the sense of
how you look at it look at my analogy
that i use and there's no one
in that category
that can pull off exactly what bungie
has done
no one look at it that deal is crazy by
the way
and they have like full creative control
over whatever they do or whatever they
want to go do she's like don't look at
me
here's some uh breaking news for ea just
said that they're open and looking um at
acquisition opportunities yeah of course
just came up with so uh all right so
okay we'll get into that here in a
second so we got uh hero avo with five
dollar super chat bungie went to
playstation and said we're pregnant and
the child came out great
that's wow
[Music]
okay
that was that caught me off guard
i got it we got a two dollars for
kendrick hardy bungee for the streets
then we got a two dollar super chat some
friends cracking
don't forget
apple got bungee microsoft pregnant uh
pregnant microsoft raised halo
what are you saying are they saying
abandon their child what's wrong with
y'all
what he's saying is he's saying in fact
she can see that baby with apples
michael raised that baby so we got we
got a two dollar street drive from king
one supreme bungie the evolution
i don't think it really quite works but
look at it though i mean yeah
you tried man
then we got to find out the strip chat
from jonathan b
she bungee said i don't really want your
life
i don't really want your last name let
me self publish jim said okay darling
yo they they are ridiculous with these
men then we got uh a two dollar subject
from kindred hardy
bungie is pokemane budgie has harm of
tricks
oh no a hairy
hair about harold yeah
look all i know is pokey man i guess i'm
not the the you know the biggest fan of
pokeman but that chick has literally
built an empire off of stuff so yeah you
can't really say too much man she
hustled her whole entire thing and then
we got a 10 i was super enough to list
22 my thoughts
sony revenue from bungie games being
multi-player games as a service with
spartacus premiere first person shooter
developer hating one ip uh
one
party uh studio bungie cash flow for
content movie uh make movies tvs with uh
sony pictures
i definitely understand that so i want
to talk about this one
real quick
what jeff krupp said jeff grubb
mentioned that the move was finalized
recently they've been working on it for
a while but it could have fallen through
if not for uh for a b k
i don't know what abk stands for do you
guys
no okay
but anyway regardless
and um here
that's most likely what it is here's how
i
see
this happen
i see
i see activision
not activision i see bungie and
playstation probably had some dialogue
and bungie was like and playstation was
like well
you guys just expect too much from this
relationship and they probably put down
those negotiations for a while
and then you know because it was still
on the table but it was one of those
things we're like we'll think about it
and they never they'd never call the
bank he's like after that that that that
date they just never got the call back
and i honestly feel like
probably because to me if this happened
six months ago exactly how it was said
because hulk said that he thinks that
you know to my knowledge what i
interpreted his words for i don't want
to speak for the uh the man but it
sounded like he said that it could have
fallen through and picked back up
i feel like maybe the activision thing
happened
and then they went back to because
because if you notice they had the same
verbiage as the bethesda deal and
the uh the activision deal
this deal isn't done it's still in the
works
and to me it feels like after the
activision thing happened
they went
hey yo bungie is that deal still on the
table like
and i think that's when that happened
because to me
sure they might have been working on
this for months
but
i honestly and truly do feel like the
activision thing is what
pushed sony because if you think about
it this is completely unlike sony to
give so much content control to someone
okay and i feel like yeah and i feel
like the activision thing happened
and then they were like
we can't afford microsoft to buy this
company we're just got to give them what
they want
even though how crazy it sounds
and then at least we keep destiny from
being an exclusive one second king
yeah
and people don't realize too it's just
like the call of duty thing
because they're buying them sure it
might be multiply it i'm still thinking
matter and all that that's up in the air
i don't think it's 100 clear with that
but destiny i'm pretty sure is staying
on all platforms yeah yeah even though
even though that it's going to stay on
platforms king you know well just as i
do we already know that you get that
destiny marketing that's big and they
will have that for here on out after
this deals
dlc all that stuff
what'd you say king okay
um
you said this is unlike sony
but this is like gym
yeah this is the house that jim built
and
jim has a level of autonomy moving
inside this sony space like no ceo at
sony's ever had
the moment
his predecessor was out the door he
dropped the price on playstation now
so you already knew that was a matter of
contention
he cleaned up
the whole european landscape
he went and cleaned up the whole eastern
landscape
he's made
and he's the father of the most
profitable
playstation error not only now is the
playstation 4. not only that though you
remember how there was uh the different
subsidiaries
like you know they had their own like
set games set mindsets
globalization happened and it's under
one rule one direction and literally
it's just been smooth but you're able to
control things in a different manner
now coming to this deal
i don't think see because
they were they were trying to sell shout
out to jess they were trying to sell to
microsoft at a lower price point
microsoft didn't care about their terms
yeah
they weren't creative freedom so so
right you're a third-party developer
and
you want to be purchased so in your
thoughts of wanting to be purchased that
means that you want to be beholden to
this house
you're not going to come and go anytime
you want
so as a company
that's not what we're looking for we're
building game pass situation here
so you have to look at the company that
did say yes
to this because i'm pretty sure ea
looked at it and said now you got my
dude
i'm pretty sure that other companies
looked at it and said um
you have to look at the company to agree
to this deal
knowing wholeheartedly
what was entailed in it
and that will give you the direction
that that company is going in because
that means they are locked step and this
is one of the first four ways that
they're throwing into that field so you
understand and know there's no surprises
out of this whole thing see people gonna
tell me to keep the same energy that i
kept when activision deal went down yeah
boy
you are not getting another call of duty
game after these next two you're done
son
like people think that they're still
coming it's not going to not happen
after the three those were on the table
yeah
that's already this contract is
will be honored that's what he said all
obligations
this is a different animal like as far
as the contract goes because
i'm not privy to the whole white pages
and this is not a finished deal it'll be
finished in a second yeah
but again
it's agreed to in principle and it will
pass
this is my hopes that it will because it
benefits sony as a company because it
fits a deficiency but it also changes
the narrative that you guys have for
sony and the thoughts that you feel that
sony is this wall garden the the garden
is being broken down the wall is being
torn ashunder and it's going to be day
and day at some point in time because
whenever one of these bungee games come
out
that's date and day on pc that's
on another console that's a date and
date someplace else
so
at what point in time where all those
little stories that you tell yourself
that day and date is not going to matter
and it's not going to be on p it's going
to be everywhere i'd be shocked if it
doesn't happen by the end of this
generation like all games no i think
about the end of this year i think i
think god of war
actually i think ragnarok all the games
in general yeah well i think ragnarok is
going to be the one game
that they're going to they don't jim
don't care i don't know about ragnarok
it has to be a game that big that you
can't turn away from i don't know though
that's right
he's going to force your hand watch it's
going to be something that you you can't
do it with gran turismo yeah yeah your
horizon definitely can't do it
but but i'm going to tell you right now
that new god of war
no
2018 release i mean they just released
the 2018 release and what's funny about
the the pc releases i'm hearing a lot of
dudes saying oh it doesn't matter
playstation will still have the better
versions of the votes but now uh awesome
also do you remember if i remember i
knew i saw it it was the rtx mode or
something like that they were showing
off it looks really weird but y'all
noticed there was extra animation detail
though so i was
uh how does the console have the better
version when all the extra full vision
is already filled on pc
looking days going it's a whole
different experience when you change
that flv slider
well i tell you this man when i hear
stuff like that when i say oh ps5 is
going to have to superior version over
pc no sure if you got a potato pc
what maybe but nah realistically nah man
like yo y'all gotta they got to stop
with that too stop holding yeah
not only that like i do want to just say
this
epic the like the first deal that
playstation or that sunday night but
they gave him like a quarter billion
dollars and then they turned right back
around i think they gave him 250 more
million though it was it was something
like some astronomical number again like
seven months later or something crazy
like that so custom games is coming to
pc i was more surprised that um god of
war and i don't know where i thought
about it but god of war came to steam
first oh
yeah that was the epic story yeah
let me let me let me explain what that
whole epic deal is
first of all they're getting fortnite
money
yeah yeah
to be in a partnership with epic in any
form of capacity you know the unreal
engine is going to be all over the place
you know microsoft has uh uh uh
engines that they use like speed tree
and stuff like that that's there that
other companies actually get a chance to
use so
why not uh sony
you know why not sony have their hand in
the most used uh uh
middleware
in the game why not so
i think that's where where they hold
thought pattern was because remember
they can get tons of money from
microsoft because more microsoft studios
is using these unreal engines than
anybody else
i think when it comes to the whole
bungee thing
and why things went the way they did let
me get this super chat real quick before
you move on two dollars from carlos
uh i double dipped alvarado i wasn't
gonna say because i'm gonna butcher his
name but okay carlos alvarado
i double dipped on god of war it's fire
on pc day and day okay uh i have a day
and day incoming i believe that
i haven't played it on pc yeah i've been
playing on pc on pc yet no i think and i
will not sit here and play on my pc like
i don't buy
but yeah no no no i'm glad you said that
no no no i'm glad you said that though
because there are people again who keep
acting like they're going to leave what
they're comfortable with and go to
something that they're not familiar or
something they don't really you know i
mean that you're not gonna if you ain't
building a pc
yet
or last year you expect me to believe
you're gonna build a one just because
ragnarok or someone going to go to be no
you're going to stay where you are
you're going to find something else to
latch on to you're going to be back on
twitter you're talking about something
else and then finding ways to find a
magnifying glass look at the xbox and
say xbox is going out of business
but then
we're gonna be right back to square one
because it's gonna keep happening how
many times have we had this conversation
where dudes like i'm done with
playstation
double playstation i'm not gonna buy the
next shot i'm not gonna buy this yeah
here we are they're still hyping up
every single game oh i agree but as far
as the bungie thing oh my god we got a
two dollar super chat from lord metro
sony definitely is the beta cause in
this deal
oh no there we go no
there was a train d road close to me
it's not this it was that train
all right so so here's what my opinions
are microsoft denied
the acquisition when bungie approached
them or they approached bungie i don't
know which one it was uh they i did hear
about it when it happened last year but
i think there's differences going on
microsoft
wanted
bungie they didn't need bungie
microsoft already has
a grasp on a multiplayer aspect they
don't necessarily need bungie to fill it
yeah when sony went to them they went to
them
at a place of weakness they went to them
at a place of are multiplayers lacking
they went to them in a place of our
competition has decided to open their
book after 15 years our competition is
buying everything they can and we know
and we've heard rumors because if i've
heard rumors that i trust i know
i know damn well they've heard it
we know that
well let me finish this real quick
we know microsoft has been in talks with
you in the past in the past like six
months to buy you
what how why did that fall through and
then budgies just straight up and like
they want our ass
uh
we told them we told them we wanted to
maintain independence and we wanted an
open relationship and they said that's
cute we'll talk later
and they walked out the door
and then sony and then sony looked at
them was like what if we have that open
relationship what if we we we we we'll
take care of the kids you know we'll
raise them we know you gotta we know you
got a bun in the oven we'll raise that
too or you know
we'll help get destiny off to college
he's like and then at the end of the day
when all this is over
we'll give you all a golden parachute
and if you guys don't like what we're
doing
you could just leave at any time
and i think sony was just in that
position where it's like look
we need someone to work on our uh on our
multiplayer and i think bungie might not
necessarily
they don't have independence but i think
they'll have a lot more responsibility
in the sony platform than the other
studios
i personally feel like these other
studios that's making multiplayer games
for playstation i would not be surprised
if they all go through bungie maybe not
directly but bungie will be looking at
them to see if these games play nice
that they can actually work in this
sequel
yeah and then if and then after they
work with bungie budgets okay now you
could go see playstation because the
mistress is gone we good like
it's like
i just i feel like that's what happened
bungie would just say uh you know they
they had sony
they had the man because at the end of
the day
i don't think sony
was in a horrible position but sony is
doing what we've asked them to do it's
like look
i personally feel like when it comes to
fallout 4 fallout franchise they need a
studio making that sooner rather than
later i don't want to wait 10 years for
a fallout franchise but
they're they're doing what i feel like
microsoft should do with the fallout
franchise it's like start working on
that now not six years from now because
what
this
is for all you dudes
that talk about
sony is nurturing
they raise their companies up and they
grow more we're going to talk about that
here in a second oh talk about that here
i got a whole topic for that sony
they're so organic man so if you don't
get off my lawn
so i i do feel like what's gonna end up
happening is i think mike uh you know
microsoft didn't want it because they
had halo and i don't think microsoft
necessarily thought sony would buy them
but they're like look even if they buy
them we have halo we have gears
we have c at these with the millions we
have plenty of these these games that we
don't necessarily need bungie sure i'm
sure if if bungie would have been
realistic with their demands
when it come to what microsoft wanted
microsoft would have bought bungie last
year yo
when they was in talks with them bungie
had jason
look at he got jason
yup
bye
at the end of the day
at the end of the day king
what's happening here
is you got a little like you know you
get you got it it's like you got a woman
that's been through a really rough
relationships like really bad one she's
had to get the she she's had to get the
uh the
uh what what's the thing the god website
no
no
no no no no no no
she's had to get she's had to get
restraining orders for multiple men in
the past and now that this new dude
rolling up on her she's like she's like
okay you're like i'm feeling you i'm
feeling you but what can you do for me
like i i need i need something
regardless if it's regardless if it's
humor that's what's happened here bungie
has went through
publisher to publisher from microsoft to
activision and then they're like look we
are not doing this again like you're
going to you're going to give us
everything we want or we walk it off
because at the end of the day budgie's
still a nice looker bungie can go
anywhere she wants it's hot as hell like
i i've never yo i've never i've no i
don't y'all can go and find me another
developer that has went through as much
breakups and still walking out here
looking like hot fire listen to me when
i'm telling you this she lost her best
like she gave her best to microsoft and
they out here doing it up you know like
because halo was back the king is back
baby so when she was in game pass
remember microsoft used them again
got him in game pass then when halo
dropped in game pass you can get up out
of here
you can get ahead hit the step sir she's
like oh you gonna do that to me this is
how you go treat me you eating i thought
we were supposed to be exclusive nah man
you talking about that street move man
and stuff i told you get that stuff up
off the playstation but you ain't won't
listen to me like that i'ma do whatever
i want you'll learn
ain't nobody gonna treat you like me
all right so six million let's go to the
last part
let's go to the the last two parts i'm
gonna put them into one
uh we got a two dollar superchat from
spartan ghost seventeen
uh gotcha oregon uh organic bungee combo
box dudes was capping and then we got uh
yeah once uh one dollar super chat from
here i definitely appreciate the uh
support thank you now
let's talk about the future of bungie
and let's talk about this organic stuff
before we do that i see it's 450 people
in here now please hit the like button
to get us to 200 likes before the end of
the podcast please 200 great
three i want three well listen listen
listen
get us up to
250 likes and i'll show you what the
back of this jacket do
oh god we gotta tell you
you want to see the back of this jacket
we got a two dollar super chat from
smart and go 17 where all the inside is
that now
all right all right all right so let's
get to the good stuff man all right so i
want your brief brief don't don't go
into a huge
tantrum uh a huge rant
i want to say rant king you know just
where you think the future of bungie and
you think like matter
maybe if they make a destiny theory do
you think these are going to be
exclusive or you think they're going to
remain multiplied and then let's talk
about the elephant in the room the big
elephant in the room and that's
is bungie an organic growth for the
playstation first party studios
king is gonna take pretty much the the
ender of the podcast because i know him
with this topic
i'm gonna be mad brief with it okay king
order 1886 that word growth organic i
mean because it's done it's done you're
not gonna hear that anymore
all right so
listen i i told you already i don't i
don't see another playstation after this
and i and i don't i don't i'm not saying
it despite you or hurt your feelings or
or say anything like that i'm telling
you uh
in marketing uh research and development
um
if you can remove all of that
uh from
the bloat because that's that's a lot of
money spent there
and you can go to exactly what y'all are
great at and and literally
y'all are great
at developing
games making games
and once you realize
that that whole stuff is inside you that
that playstation app whatever it's going
to be called
could be on the xbox platform it can be
on a uh uh whatever uh netflix box is
going to be whatever amazon's luna is
that can be there you have the the ips
that can actually live and you can just
make games and make money without tying
yourself to hardware with fake numbers
and all this stuff and trying to make
make ends meet
what i've seen with this acquisition
is that's what bungie is about
bungie is about developing games they
don't care about no hardware they're
just about putting it wherever they can
get their bread at whatever street
corner going pumped up that's gonna
happen
so
when is jim gonna look over because i
already think jim has been looking over
at that whole aspect of it because they
did tell you that they was cutting back
on the playstation 5 development right
now because of what was going to
production of it where microsoft said
they're ramping up they're pushing it
harder so you got to look at where both
companies are going and what their
positioning is in certain aspects of it
and where they can generate the most
amount of money from
all right so you're talking about a
trillion dollar company and a billion
dollar company a trillion dollar company
doesn't care about research and
development they don't care about
production costs because they all they
that is used as a
a price to play the game
but what happens when you no longer want
to play the game in that same manner
when nintendo didn't want to play the
game in that whole power structure race
nobody could ever foretold what they
were going to do and how they was going
to achieve it but they were successful
in what they did and how they're going
about it because they make great
software so what they realize is the
hardware at the end of the day matters
when it fits their purpose
their purpose has always been nintendo
on the go they went right back to the
dna and they went right back to where
they started
sony started as a developer
when they decided to go back to their
dna because remember they got in this
game to kick nintendo's teeth in
job mission accomplished
you already did that
you have made your brand a household
name you have made your console
something to be feared
but right now
is it about the fight or is it about the
win
so
that will be the show
on the switch
and will be the show on xbox
destiny three
on everybody
it's about
winning now
if you can't win when god of war is
launched on everybody at one time
it forget about these fanboys and all
that other stuff because that doesn't
jim don't care
goes back to rebranding
playstation
well that's what i'm saying goes back to
playstation studios
remember when i told you
that logo yeah that logo
and they said
that means nothing
brother brother that means everything
like
games did was xbox
you put yourself in a place where
that
logo is synonymous now with a great
quality yeah exactly thank you yeah
exactly yeah so
that's their stamp of approval so when
you got the standpoint necessary and
it's on the sun let me ask you a
question this right so a lot of people
can't find a playstation 5 right now
right
but what if they were just developing
games
let microsoft worry about that
oh let nintendo worry about that we're
gonna put these bomb games out and
you're gonna get it how you gonna get it
though they're not gonna do that though
watch this is the last one does it you
know i think they did that the thing is
so the reason why i hustle and i'm with
hustle on uh why we're not gonna see
them go away goes back to that
conversation we had with kate yeager
uh consoles will always
be around especially if they got the
support system thinking about
playstation hardware it sells itself now
the problem with playstation hardware
this time around and you just brought it
up
sony cannot guarantee you a ps5 in your
hands in fact sony's going to extreme
rates to get you a ps5 and they've done
they've done one move that really
angered me i got flack for it but i was
like listen i gotta call it out when you
cheap out on something as vital
as the heat solution for your system
when you cheap out on something is vital
to a console's lifespan and hustle you
already know you saw the comments let me
tell you something man people go oh it
works there's no issues they were you're
wrong i'm sitting going we haven't tried
a single game that pushes this box yet
so yeah longevity is always going to be
in the back of your mind for this new
unit of the ps5 because the heatsink
that we got with the og that was future
proof that's the word i like to use
future proof it was good it was going to
work the newer one
that's iffy
yeah that's still with that still if you
play yeah this old one right here i
don't care what they do and the last
thing i want to do and i'm glad you said
that the last thing i want to see by the
time we get like a little further into
jin the last thing i ever want to see
especially with sony just dropping these
new plates for the ps5 the last thing i
want to see is a redesign
of this console and they go you know you
know what yeah about them plates have
gotten more different you know i don't
want to see that because at that point
it's like hmm
yeah
yeah so that conversation came back
let's uh let's go and get hustles uh
opinion on this so hustle how do you
feel
in terms of the acquisitions and do you
feel
uh what's going to be the future for
bungie on the let's say on the xbox
platform like how do you feel they're
going to be operating
i i think it's going to be like a war
zone situation right microsoft microsoft
as we all know just quiet activation i
think that what is available on the
platforms you will always have that but
i think what they're working well
bundy's working on in the tuck is going
to be playstations up baby they pride
and joy i like to say that little halo
but i do want to be respectful and say
that that's gonna be their thing um
uh one of y'all earlier in this
conversation pretty much um they went to
bungie when the when playstation went
the money or something with the bungie
when they were desperate look at what
look at what bungie walked away with we
and we keep talking about i ain't never
seen nothing like that before the way
you walk away with
like everything you want plus more
bungee pretty much walked away with
sony's retirement fun like that
um
i want to piggyback off of what big
cloud was just talking about with the
playstation and the heating uh yeah yeah
yeah the cheaper the the cheap
alternative they went without yeah i
want y'all to know something
this generation is probably going to be
like the ps3 generation i got a feeling
because can't nobody find none of these
joints nowhere playstation xbox well you
can you can always find a series s which
is a good thing
but the the this semi chip
when
conductor
the last time you seen a digital version
of what ps4 ps4
i haven't that's the thing that's the
that's the thing is that supposed to be
the unit that we thought was going to be
uh the one they push out we don't even
see additional
they go straight for the disc and i'm
like
but this this generation started what
2021 was last year before last yeah it's
like 20 21. if this generation reaches
up to 2028 that would not surprise me
because we're gonna have to deal with
this uh chip conductor shortage at least
until 2024 from what i would understand
just according to some of the research
that i've done
so if we get a repeat of the ps3
generation and they cheapened out on
some supplies with playstation i got the
day one joint right there and hopefully
this don't know what happened to it
hopefully that happened i don't the
thing about that day one when we got
compared to what we saw
with the new one i think we good for
quite some time because yeah
what they were talking about and and
again austin evans got a lot of flak for
you know dudes came at us and i'm like
bro all he did was just compare the
boxes but i'm sure looking at it bro
when you cut out any solution that's
vital to what console's lifespan you
have to question that people think oh i
trust the sony engineers
oh god yeah yeah i trust them that they
put out a box that made the parameters
mean that it works for now what about
for longevity that's the recommended
specs yeah that's it
that it's on your line they does that
then they go the thing is is you can't
trust uh look i'm not saying these
people aren't smart they're definitely
smarter than me in that in that field
but
these type of people these smart
individuals the same people that gave us
the red ring of death
uh the issues that the ps3 had
they're the same people that made the
samsung phones explode in your ear
like look like when you're doing these
research and development for years
sometimes you're in such a tunnel vision
you overlook stuff
thank you
especially
huge problems with it and stuff
listen well we haven't touched about i
mean we haven't really pushed the boxes
yet that's the thing on charlie five
gonna come out the new ps4
they go they're gonna start using place
they're gonna start using playstation
they're gonna start using playstations
to warm apartments
i've joked about the system
i mean mine is pretty loud starts off
sounds like a jet engine
uh yeah oh that initial boot you got
that issue
oh
yeah and then it didn't stop and then it
stopped oh
like what big boy slow down start
walking sound like a big boy run up the
steps
calm down big boy calm down but um like
breathe
out your nose and your mouth
[Music]
they make more money with my strategy
and i'm telling you
somebody's going to look over and i
already know he has already
he already looked over and i don't i
don't
i don't care
how bad it hurts whoever because it
really doesn't hurt you
you know
you don't hurt at all if you pick up an
xbox controller because i've seen a lot
of you do that's the controller you use
to play the god of war on pc
all right so you've been using that
controller playing it on pc
that shows and that and let me tell you
that show them
we can make controllers then if they're
if they're bound to the controller
that app could be on the tv microsoft
has been dabbling in that whole aspect
as well
that you just walk in you pick up your
controller your app is on your
television and you're just
you're glued in
your linkedin
listen
that hardware stuff is going to go away
people said
physical wasn't going to go away i just
told you he has 700 plus digital games
yep
700 plus digital uh physical games
behind him he would have to get how many
shelves and cabinets did we used to have
back in the days a lot i'll have to get
one tubs
you know those futuristic movies where
they they like put the the the car in
like the closet it picks it up so you're
gonna see behind me just like a corvo
just swapping out the games and i'm
going to sit in there back just going
from room to room like okay no the
game's right here just moving it again
oh it was in that last room but i gotta
go all the way back around to get it
like
no it's over man
they'd never wanted to get with the
times these dudes is old funny y'all too
young to be old fuddy duddies
get off my lawn you that guy man come on
just just let it go i don't know you're
gonna say well if microsoft did it would
you keep the same attitude let me tell
you something
whatever i could pick up my controller
with because i've watched my neogeo
leave i watched my nec leave i watched
my sega leave i could watch any one of
these two disappear
but as long as i can get their games
that's their legacy
the hardware was just something for me
to just say you know that's what they
was at this is this is where i was at
but if they make it that i'm able to
gain no matter what wherever
i'm down
i've been there
disagree yeah i definitely understand i
agree i mean you can hear your opinion
of course but long live whoops
long live physical media
just hell with it let it burn yeah
yeah what's funny is hustle
how much did you spend on that uh that
those n64 uh
n64 games their hustle those those uh
wrestlers
it varies
[Laughter]
cost me 75. the other copy of no mercy
cost me 35. they both work
um but like no more like that was the
most i spent on it i think
no more than that but i hold on hold on
i got an arcade machine let me get these
two dollar super chats real quick uh
that has
65 000 games and 135 consoles in it
thank you
you can you can grab all your consoles
and try to run out your house i'm gonna
walk in i'm gonna pick my table topper
and i'm gonna walk out the house with 65
000 you couldn't do that with a bunch of
book bags he was like
and i've seen that that they did they
got those
king was having that when he was having
that built they're like what do you want
materials want us to use for this well
considering it's huge if my house burns
down i want that to survive so make that
as some fireproof stuff that way you
know it comes out i don't have to grab
that so you know stuff starts going bad
i'll just leave that downstairs it'll be
fine
uh we gotta find all this triple trap
from hero evo oh my god i i don't know
if i should read this no bungie on that
blue viagra growth
wow we got a we got a 8.99 super chat
for uh from
methi i dude you're just gonna have to
deal with that man
i got you his name was
what was it
let me show it
we see here we're having a pronunciation
class right now
and this this is nothing against like
people that pronounce it because i i
hate if black people have like a
pronunciation of their name on that uh
this is me being this is me barely being
able to speak english so i can
definitely not speak other stuff so king
that no more uh ps console would happen
if microsoft allowed the ps store in the
xbox what a site that would be
uh and i think that's all for now yeah
okay so here okay you understand what
type of what what what level
of dominance
phil will have
do you understand what type of what
what type of trophy would go on top of
his wall
did you do you
if that was ever to be a case and you
pop on your xbox and you go because the
greatest thing that phil did so far was
sony
studios
mlb the show
game pass day and date
in your wildest dreams
that was not achievable i want you to go
back to that moment to that second to
that date
and play it over in your head because
that's when pigs could fly
because a lot of you guys said man when
pigs would fly that'll happen
wait wait
get out there and get your fishing net
because he's flying
all right so
this house is game pass coming to
playstation this ain't gonna be no
playstation to put it on this is that
this is how i feel i'm glad at that
point this is how i felt when it comes
to the future of bungie and the
you know whether or not the uh sony does
the
growth that's natural we'll say that
okay first off let's do the growth
that's natural anyone that's saying this
in the chat
you're capping i i get it
they there is a lot more examples now i
was 100
on certain people's side until i was on
a podcast with k mega shout out to him
he said something that i really
resonated with and i didn't really think
about it till he said it he said
i can't really say something's a natural
growth when you bought them 15 years
after working with them that's not
natural that's just buying them after
you've worked with them and then i
started thinking about it something like
compulsion even um the people who make
fraternal they've been around for a
while but i don't think the house house
house
i don't think they've been properly
funded to really elevate their studio
you know what i'm saying so i'm looking
at like a potion house mark uh even blue
point to a point uh because they've
never got their own like i see that as
being
uh you know a growth that they've that
they're really what's the word that they
love you oh i got to show them the back
of the jacket they hit it up hold on
they did they did yeah my bad okay so i
see that as
natural growth
but i don't see
insomniac as natural goats because to me
what i see when i see them buying
insomniac after working with them for 10
to 15 years is
they funded that studio and insomniac
naturally grow their studio with the
money that playstation gave them which
insomnia could have got that from a lot
of other people it's just sony signed on
for these these studios and that's why i
personally feel like let's let's see
this real quick hold up
i
where's the light up effects i thought
you had a chris jericho jack
oh that is crazy
that's cool we need a jacket like that
king
you know what that cost more jackets
i'm not saying it needs to be made out
of that stuff but i'm saying that wolf
needs to be the iop mascot that's how
well okay so let me go let me go back to
what i was saying
i do feel like certain studios they've
naturally grown but all i feel like
certain students like insomniac they've
just gave them money throughout the
years insomniac has grown their studios
it'd be different if they bought them 15
years ago and they've made these games
with them like if you really think about
it
it saw me i kind of go to microsoft to
get funding for install for sunset
overdrive because playstation wouldn't
fund it yeah they wouldn't fund it
without owning sunset overdrive so that
that concept right there
it makes it not necessarily look bad but
you know it doesn't really stand with
that natural growth that people talk
about now if you look at it from
microsoft
sony now what i will say
is we saw bethesda what did todd howard
say when fallout 76
uh flopped at first first person he
called was phil spencer uh that
microsoft helped put oblivion on the
xbox platform uh you can honestly say
that nintendo maybe a little bit less
nintendo when it comes to third party
but especially sony and playstation have
naturally grown organically grown with
all of these publishers throughout the
past 15 years because they've worked
with them every damn game
so it's just like i don't see that
mindset i don't like it would be
different if they buy these studios they
bought like a little tiny studio and
then they just groaned them throughout
the year sony doesn't do that
sony's like oh you like that game oh
that's cool how much you need oh we'll
give you the money if you let us own the
ip i know you're the one that invented
it you're the one that thought about it
but you we our money comes with cost we
ain't doing this unless you give us the
ip all right that's good here's the
money and then insomniac took the money
walked away with it and they grew their
stuff they were the ones that found the
talent they're the ones that grew the
studios the way they work you know what
kills me though um quantity dreams i
think that was a miss opportunity
personally quite the dreams i think
super massive games wasn't it
yeah supermaster games too uh quantity
dreams is not owned by anybody they're
independent i'm pretty sure that would
be picked up soon but superman they're
the people
when these
yeah masters got picked up by netflix
right
no no no no no no no that should matter
they they're just making like a mo uh
they're they're about to finish their
their last game but it's just like until
dawn fantastic studio yeah
sony just let that go um quantum drink
fantastic studio sony just let that go
um
brady at dawn
yeah this fantastic studio they just let
that go like it's
to your point though
they
they're not as organic as they they they
lead you to believe and i think that's a
narrative that people want to believe
because they want to turn them into
something that told them that they they
want you to believe that they're less of
the two evils they want you to believe
that that this is their proper choice
and and isn't that always the thing same
thing with pepsi and coke you know like
oh pepsi
uh pets baby kittens every night before
they go to sleep you know and
and coca-cola kicks dogs you know so
they they tell you things to to to make
you believe stuff listen
sony has been dealing in practices that
haven't been great microsoft doesn't
deals and practices that aren't great
and
you have to find out exactly where you
lie you lie with games
right so none of these dudes have grown
anything organically
none of them and that's why i want to
point out to uh
th this uh whatever your name is i'm not
going to try to butcher it that's
business addict just like xbox throwing
a bag of money to buy publishers stop
the cap it's pretty bland y'all are xbox
stands okay whatever you want to call us
this is really related to to my stock
but it's up but i gotta i gotta roast
them hold up it stopped but i gotta roll
it
you know
i just want to say one point you know
how you roast them
by having it
ignorant look look at that be a man
behind your words put your money up and
i get that but i do want to point out
this and then i won't address anything
ever again in the chat look
at the end of the day i we literally
king just said none of these companies
have ever really done that uh none of
them you know none of them actually
organic anything the difference is is a
lot of xbox people and it looks like big
cloud we're not saying that xbox did
like we're we're look at the end of the
day the only difference between
microsoft going out there and buying
studios and playstation is microsoft has
you can't outbid me money and
playstation does it when it came to
warframe and microsoft and sony and was
trying to bid for that there was like up
to 1.5 billion sony pulled off they've
been they've been for uh warzone splash
damage all that company they've been for
wb did any of that sound like organic
growth king no so so you needed to tell
me if they won those bids they were just
gonna be like okay now we've won the
bids uh we're just gonna sell the
companies yeah like no the only reason
they're not buying these kids
the only reason they're not buying these
studios is because companies like
microsoft companies like google
companies like apple can come in there
and quadruple to five times the amount
of their bid every single time almo if
you look at it every time sony loses a
bid it's nine times out of ten to
neither microsoft tencent or google and
that's because
sony wants to be the superhero platform
if you want to be the superhero platform
you got to have one particular character
on there that's bad though
i i don't think they want to be able to
i don't think they want to be the
superhero platform well i'm talking
about what they're doing
yeah right now
they have an ip
and the dealing with with marvel and
disney and knowing what's the pulse of
of of
the now generation
yeah and the now generation they saw how
spider-man rang off it's they see the
sails in the movies so they look at
other ips that they're able to touch in
that space and they want to reverberate
in the same manner so i just believe
that they have a finger on the pulse i
don't believe that they want it to be a
superhero box actually they just want to
sell games
the reason why i said that because it
really looked like they wanted to be the
the helm like the you know
yeah like that type of stuff i think
because spider-man was so successful and
because of the
arrangement that people were sitting
there acting like it's not fair to xbox
gamers that
despite that sony could use the leverage
of having the spider-man movie license
and they can leverage that to getting
whatever they want for marvel but at the
end of the day sony's using what they
have to their advantages like
microsoft's using what they have to
their advantage and you won't see me
complaining so it's just like look like
i can guarantee you when sony was about
to get yanked off the mcu and they were
going back over and over again so he's
like we want a wolverine game
and they use that advantage there you go
to it and it's just like
we got to stop with this organic stuff
because at the end of the day none of
these companies have really organically
grown anything i will give like the
initiative i do think they're granted
they're literally growing that studio
from infancy so that i will give that
i'll give some of the smaller studios
but as far as like the coalition that
was built from the ground uh actually if
you think about it uh
king
microsoft's organically growing more
studios 343 coalition the initiative
made from the ground up to make these
games
well not not a dog is is is one nice
they bought naughty dog yeah they
purchased naughty dog naughty dog
before them
yeah but they were yeah no no no don't
don't don't do that don't do that don't
do that yeah okay see what what attic is
talking about is no i know what he means
yeah were they purchased or were they
grown
right so you got to talk about what was
grown in-house or what was purchased
and
technically
naughty dog was purchased they have
games because i had games on my 3do i
had way of the warrior
yeah
so i could take it back if if people
want to pull out hardware let's pull up
that hardware
and you know so
nah man it's just they're not organic
that's a farce that's a lie and this
deal proves how organic they are not so
it's it's it's absolutely i really
whatever
yeah i really want to see microsoft get
aggressive though in this superhero uh
field i don't care two two snaps about i
don't think i i don't know go upstairs
and play
marvel avengers right now there's two
characters that that would benefit
drastically on the
what's going on spawn
punisher
i do think
don't they gotta go
360.
i'm telling you right now i do think it
would i do think
king you can't tell me we got a
first and pixel bit g nope naughty dog
started making gaming on the
video
yes okay no no okay so we're we're we're
moving past i appreciate the uh super
chat king you can't tell me
that a punisher made by the coalition
wouldn't wouldn't be lit
or poor after looking at another
i have to look at what netherrealm did
with uh spawn and you seeing um you know
just that
literally having a conversation with a
dude that
you know what it got to the point right
now when i go we got the old hotness we
talking about noodles
but see i walk upstairs every day and i
turn on my xbox
and i go straight to game pass and i say
i go to recently added and if it's the
same game that's in in in the square in
the front
i take a sire relief
and i go let me clean up some more of
these games that i've been playing
brother i'm still playing death's door
so i'm going to tell you this i don't
care about the punisher being made
that's coming out in 2025 i don't
i'm dealing with the stuff that's
happening now and it would it be lit
yes
would it be fantastic
[Laughter]
thought i had when it comes to the
future of bungie i do think that their
future stuff's gonna be exclusive uh i
think destiny's gonna stay on
multi-platform there's no reason to i
know there's a lot of so you see a
revamp of the bethesda deal i mean catch
up you see like a revamp of the bethesda
still sort of in this like all future
stuff like all um commitments will be
held and and
yeah and i get people are saying that
the way this was structured
that's impossible but i feel like sony's
funding it they could easily
manipulate bungie like that's true i get
that you know they got they got the law
behind them but sony got the money
behind them so it's just like at the end
of the day when it comes down to this um
the i do think do you guys real quick
king because i know the rest don't play
destiny you think it's possible we know
right now that destiny 2 is supposed to
be
continuing do you think that sony might
push for a destiny 3 just to shut it off
from the xbox
i don't know probably so but i um in the
contract they they play that we shutting
it off from anybody and bungie gonna
shut off their lights and walk out the
house because
listen
this is gonna be the first time that
you're going to see a sony company
because they're sony company out there
under the sony brand i i've watched that
activision thing with them in its
entirety
and i've seen
if they don't like a situation they give
you the middle finger i thought it was
an anomaly
with with with microsoft
and you know all they asked microsoft
they pulled the tina turner and said all
i want is my name you can key the kids
i'm up out of here just i just want my
name i want my last name too i don't
wanna see this
and they left out there that way and
then they learned
they've learned contract to contract
this is the greatest contract that i've
seen so far as far as the developer go
give me money i do what i want god bless
see you later like excuse you
so
i added um yo
i'm is that for me they play that bs
over there with them boys them boys
about to leave and take the baby the
house the guard and the mortgage
i just think that i wouldn't be
surprised if they try something
they try it and they're going to get bit
so what was you saying bit clyde because
we about to wrap this up
all right
okay so you know
first off i want to thank everyone
coming through add up to like 450 people
uh first first off i want to say you do
not want to miss the iron lords podcast
this sunday at 1 pm on the channel that
you're watching this definitely that
like button if you guys enjoyed the
podcast uh subscribe to the channel i
know a lot of you ain't subscribed uh
i don't know at this point i see a lot
of you in there if you're not subscribed
there's a little subscribe button right
down here uh click that it's it's red if
you haven't subscribed now if it's great
leave it alone leave it alone if it's
great you can hit the little bell icon
beside the gray thing if you want but
you know i appreciate everyone for
coming through we got a five dollar
troop trip from hero evo catch you on
the lord's day some twitter folks about
to catch these hands just kidding peace
and love fellas now hustle and motivate
what's going on with you do you have
anything that you want to tell the realm
yeah yeah um
i am currently on twitch.tv slash
hustling motivate getting my teeth
bashed inbound charlie three actually
and i am preparing
you know since i'm somebody said i was
an xbox fan boy i know you weren't
talking to me when this is my favorite
series of all time i know you weren't
talking to me anyway see you did that i
was going to be petty and just say hey
you want to see my psn i was going to do
that because my
speaks for values but you got it now i'm
i'm everywhere hustling motivate um i
will stream what's tomorrow wednesday
yep yeah thursday
i'll probably stream back thursday i'm
gonna try to finish uncharted 3. i don't
know where i'm at in the game i'm on a
boat or something who knows but
i'm streaming follow me on twitter just
so you can stay abreast of all the news
addict
one hell of a show sir big clown i want
to say thank you and king thank you all
so oh wait y'all make sure y'all catch
big cloud on this channel big cloud
gaming the rgt podcast comes on every
friday at 5 00 p.m eastern standard time
correct sir yes sure and as you all know
the iron lords
that's another football season is over
every sunday 1 p.m eastern standard time
and you don't want to miss either one of
these episodes
yeah and you know first thing i do want
to say is there will be a review
tomorrow
i think it's like seven or eight i'm not
gonna go into logistics on a game i'm
not to say the game i'm sure you guys
can sure you can know what the game's
going to be but i will be putting up a
review on that game tomorrow uh seven or
eight i have to double check the time
i'm not gonna accidentally schedule it
and break nda that would that would be
horrible
but definitely catch on that
king david what is going on man you got
any new announcements
yeah um tomorrow you can catch me at uh
2xp
uh it's gonna be lit it's gonna be a
show we're gonna be out here we're gonna
be acting i'm gonna be out there with my
boys
from the midwest oh acting crazy it's
gonna be crazy um fridays you can catch
me
at uh dolph castle x 9 p.m we can see
the boy talk about all this uh premium
stuff all this opulence all this since
y'all y'all like to have a lot of
product
this is this is the only physical i need
in my life oh man this right here
beautiful ridiculous oh the watch is
killing me oh you don't have i'm
surprised you don't have one those
life-sized iron man armor oh no my boy
got that stuff i'm not
[Laughter]
r2d2
that cost him eight grand life size r2d2
so
and he this does all the
all that stuff
my wife
thought it was him making the sounds
with his mouth she's like why is he
doing that i said no that's something
she said oh definitely no
that's that's a definite you don't even
look in his direction so my boy went
life-sized all the stuff all the statues
in his house his life size and he then
got a couple of guys in the group to do
that
that's a different tax bracket than this
kid over here and i'm not trying to do
that sir unless you want me to be
pawning these things here
that's not happening sir
so i i know how to stay in my lane i'm
like sony
oh my god
i see
i'm playing over there in that big ass
sandbox
i stay my little behind over here i
spend my little three billion over there
you know picking and choosing what i
like sir thank you
all right so big cloud gaming what what
you got going on with you man
you got any anything you want to tell
people man
uh well appreciate the invite it was a
hell of a show always a pleasure i
appreciate y'all
rgt like the homie hustler said every
friday 5 p.m eastern standard time uh
again thank you guys you guys want to
follow me big cloud gaming youtube
twitch twitter um i keep saying this
because there's truth i'm gonna tell
them my fair but you guys you're in for
a treat we got a lot of stuff um lined
up
uh let's just put it like that big
thanks i have a question before we go
what's up do you have a new uh host do
you have a new co-host on the rg2
podcast i haven't seen sean
we got two
man we got man
now we got two new awesome uh members we
got red hood 420 and we got
and we got um uh paul hunter aka nextgen
from uh twitter so that's our two new
additions to the cash and that's right
shows have been great straight gaming
you already know how we how we do it but
also tomorrow we'll be streaming the uh
state of place you guys want to come
hang out with yours truly come on you
mean the state of delay
everybody watching this um we will not
be streaming that so you should probably
go watch his uh
yeah hit that subscribe button hit that
subscribe i'll be reporting on it once
that game get delayed hey yo blaze
hey make sure you put some shea butter
on the back of your knees if you don't
get delayed we need you on rgt so you
can bend the knee yeah hey listen listen
listen if if it don't get denate delayed
he already i already told him he got to
come on iron lords i better knee cause
that's what his deal was made at so i
ain't going on nobody else's shoulder
bending me but on guarding them the boy
already know like i said you need to
belong to me put it in the box ship it
off over here thank you thank you hey
make sure you put a lot of shea butter
on the back of your knees
[Laughter]
and it's like i said you guys
so subscribe to the iron lords podcast
channel definitely go and subscribe to
all these gentlemen as well uh follow
king on his stats